So, this came to me because this is my
Sabbath devotions that I was having. Um,
I took all of Sabbath being sick just to
read the Bible and kind of think about
it. And so,
I thought just like me in my life, you
guys might have things going on that you
truly need
to know that God is there for you.
Um, so
this study is to remind all of us of the
truth that cannot be shaken from us. God
will always persevere
and he will always win.
No matter what Satan tries,
no matter the schemes he puts into
motion, his defeat has already been
written and prophesied.
Let's take a closer look. If you will go
with me to
Ezekiel 28 11-19,
it says, "Moreover, the word of the Lord
came unto me, saying, Son of man, take
up a lamentation upon the king of Tyrus,
and say unto him, thus saith the Lord
God, thou sealest up the sum, full of
wisdom, and perfect in beauty." Let's
continue.
Thou hast been in Eden, the garden of
God. Every precious stone was thy
covering. This is where we know they're
talking about Satan
because only Satan was in Eden
in that garden with all precious stones
on him with coverings as we know he was
described in the Bible elsewhere. So
with the start, the sardis, topaz, and
the diamond, the barrel, the onyx, and
the jasper, the sapphire, the emerald,
and the carbuncle, and gold. The
workmanship of thy tam tambberts, and of
thy pipes was prepared in thee in the
day that thou was created.
Thou art the anointed cherub that
coverth. More proof that it's Satan. And
I have set thee. So thou was upon was
upon the holy mountain of God. Thou
hast walked up and down in the midst of
the stones of fire. Thou was perfect in
thy ways from the day that thou was
created till iniquity was found in thee.
You're getting my notes. You're getting
me just kind of uh raw. So I hope you're
enjoying this because this is just me
kind of talking and going through what I
learned. So going further into 16, it
says, "By the multitude of thy
merchandise, they have filled the midst
of thee with violence, and thou hast
sinned. Therefore, I will cast thee as
profane out of the mountain of God, and
I will destroy thee, oh covering cherub,
from the ma midst of the fires of
stone." So here we go. We have promises
from God. I will cast you out. I will
destroy you.
And it continues in 17, thine heart was
lifted up because of thine beauty. Thy
beauty. Thou hast corrupted thy wisdom
by reason of thy brightness. I will cast
thee to the ground. I will lay thee
before kings that they may behold thee.
All right. Again, the I will statements.
These are beautiful promise from God.
promises from God. And
we have to go all the way to 19. So
let's see. 18. Thou hast defiled thy
sanctuaries by the multitude of thine
iniquities, by the iniquity of thy
traffic. Therefore will I bring forth a
fire from the midst of thee. It shall
devour thee, and I will bring thee to
ashes upon the earth in the sight of all
them that behold thee. So here's another
thing if you didn't realize though
another thought that came to me while I
was doing the study and now is that he
says I will bring thee to ashes upon the
earth in the sight of all men that
behold thee. So this is a promise of the
end of time how when the evil are
uh go to hell they will be burnt to
ashes. Even Satan will be turned to
ashes on the face of the earth.
So that is a beautiful thing to know
that there is justice that Satan will
come to an end. And so all the demons
and all of the evil people. And 19
lastly it says all they that know thee
among the people shall be astonished at
thee. Thou shalt be a terror and never
shalt thou be anymore.
It's all about what we are being told by
God. The promises, I will statements
that he will put an end to Satan, to
evil, to the demons, to everything that
is bad and we will be vindicated.
All right?
So God is saying the battle is already
decided. Why was this written in the
Bible? You have to ask yourself, why was
this even written? Because it's already
been decided who will win and who will
lose. Now, that's pretty comforting to
me because God doesn't lie.
So, Satan's judgment is set in stone.
His power is limited and his end is
certain. God's plan cannot fail.
All right.
So
let's talk about this. Make no mistake,
Satan is alive and he is active. He is
stuck on earth with us. When he was cast
to the earth,
he was stuck with us in our world.
He's everywhere that he wants to be
because unless you've asked for a
covering of God to protect you from him
and his demons daily,
he's right here.
And the choices that you make allow him
to be there.
The choices, the things you watch, the
things you do, all the stuff, the sins
you choose to keep in your life, give
him the green light to be there.
So
he wants to claim territory, spaces,
objects, and even your very life.
Life will be hard here. We know that.
And God doesn't always get his way here
on Earth.
You see, God doesn't always immediately
get it because he created humans with
free will.
And sometimes their free will is not
what God wants. And it changes things.
It changes outcomes. It hurts others. It
ends lives.
It causes destruction.
It gives in to evil.
So God allows people to choose obedience
or rebellion.
And he respects that choice.
bad things still happen because even if
you're praying again,
things may seem unanswered due to the
fallen nature of the world. And those
who you're praying for, again, their
their free will might be going against
God's will completely.
And so human sin, spiritual opposition,
and the fact that hearts must choose to
yield to God's will prevents things from
happening.
God works according to his perfect plan.
Yes. And he can use circumstances, even
when they're bad, to turn them for our
good. He promises that.
But
let's just say
this may involve
unfortunately for him
allowing challenges. This is where we
don't like hearing this. It means
allowing challenges or delays. It means
having to be refined,
taught things that might hurt and not
feel good.
Um, or demonstrate his glory,
which sounds great, but in the long run,
that means usually a lot of hardship for
us, a lot of pain. We might lose people
along the way. That might mean that
you've been praying for a loved one that
is sick and they do not get better.
And in the long run,
at for a long time, you might not know
why. Um,
and other times you realize it was
because it was their time to go. He was
being merciful. Whatever the case may
be, they didn't need to keep suffering.
But
these are the kinds of hardships that we
usually hold as bitterness.
Bitternesses towards God that keep us
from loving him and understanding him.
But we don't need to feel that way. They
are hard. But he doesn't get his way
either. He hurts with us. If you know
how much he cries with you when you cry,
how much he, as he says in the Bible,
he longs to gather us all under his
wings like chicks, like a mother hen
does. He said that. I don't remember
which verse cuz I didn't plan on saying
that, but
we know that there is that verse in the
Bible.
So he also removes things and people
that you are holding on to perhaps too
tightly or that are in his way to do so.
Ultimately his victory is assured
though. That's what I mean when he will
persevere and he will win.
He will be the victor. His victory is
assured, but he accomplishes it in
alignment with free will and his perfect
timing and knowing the best for us.
Those are the things which we don't
usually like a whole lot.
We want our timing.
We want our will to be done
in our way
thinking we know best.
But he does know better. Throughout
history, we can see actually a couple of
examples of Satan hard at work.
See,
one thing I came with, of course, is
special facts that you probably didn't
know.
Freemasons
historically
lay cornerstones in churches, government
buildings, and public structures.
This is one such example. And this
ceremony is called the cornerstone
ceremony.
These cornerstones are engraved with
masonic symbols such as a square in the
compass, dates, and ritual markings.
They are placed intentionally to claim
spiritual legal right and influence on
the people in them and mark authority
over the building according to Masonic
practices.
In some cornerstones, time capsules or
objects are embedded
which are intended as talismans or
vessels of influence.
Historical records confirm that many US
state capitals, courouses, and even
cathedrals contain Masonic cornerstones.
Let me tell you
that
most Freemasons,
as it as it infers, masons, they were
the ones who were the first architects,
usually the first brick layers, masons.
And to this day, they are the largest
percentage of general contractors whom
you contract with to have things built.
We don't usually know and they don't
usually declare that they are masons.
So, a lot of the times when we're
talking about our houses
or let's just focus more on churches.
Our churches have been built by these
people. They don't tell you that they're
Freemason. They don't tell you that
they're going to be doing the
cornerstone ceremony on it in private,
whether it's in the during the night or
when it's covered before it's finished
in any case with other Freemasons or
without and with rituals,
before it's installed.
And
it just like many other things of Satan
is markings such as hexoggrams and other
things that Satan wants to place in your
life or around you because they're
symbols that invoke demons. They give
them legal authority to be there.
And
we don't usually think about that. I've
never actually heard anyone else talk
about this,
but and I just learned about it myself,
but our churches have already legally
been spoken for. If that is the case,
that we didn't
know who built our churches
and they have this cornerstone.
It's not always, of course, when they
want to declare that it's real and that,
you know, it's obvious that they are the
ones who built it, they will show you
with clear markings and sayings on it.
But
if you weren't meant to know, you won't
know.
So, there's that. That's first example I
have for you.
The second is a very fact from John Todd
by the way, a Satanist and um I think he
was club of 300 and Illuminati member
when he came out he actually showed in
his book
that all concert halls, auditoriums,
places where they have concerts in
general and music performances
um as well as theaters and places of the
uh movie industry
are all constructed and oriented
according to ritualistic or symbolic
principles.
They cast spells and curses on it to
mesmerize and bind souls to be attracted
to its influence.
Architectural layouts and stage
placements
and acoustics even in the buildings are
deliberately designed
to enhance influence through sound and
environment.
I have another episode that's coming up
on sound and manipulation
of Satan with sound and music and so on
and what they're doing.
It'll be very interesting
after I lay this groundwork.
But this music, the sound and
environment is intentional.
In music production, master tracks, just
as John Todd said, are then carried
to the top of usually, excuse me,
the
record label building such as Capital
Records where he was put in charge and
all of the wizards and witches and um
sorcerers are called on to
quote unquote bless but put curses truly
on the master track to in to carry
mental control over the masses.
Historical evidence and testimonies from
the industry show that producers with a
cult affiliations
embed symbolic sounds, hidden messages,
and frequencies
in recordings to influence audiences.
Now,
I'm going to go ahead and backtrack a
little bit because
I don't know why I didn't give you guys
better
visuals here.
But we will go ahead and look at
cornerstone
ceremonies.
and see what it has to say again.
So, sometimes it's with a lot of pomp
and circumstance, all of the regalia
and everything. Sometimes it is not, but
let's just read here.
So the corner a cornerstone ceremony is
a public ritual often masonic that
symbolizes the beginning of a new
building's construction by laying the
cornerstone a first stone in the
foundation. It dates back to the
medieval period and is now largely
symbolic. That's what they say, but I
know better. With modern versions using
implements like corn, wine, and oil to
consecrate the stone and test its
truness.
So these are sacrifices or even um
offerings that they are giving.
Um
sometimes it's with great speaking
that they turn over the building to the
owner. That's usually with bigger things
though like the city hall like they're
saying here or districts.
But
let's just see one last thing. A
cornerstone.
What would it look like? Let's just see
here.
Oh, that is interesting. Let's take a
better look at that.
Do you see this? It's George Washington
laying
the cornerstone in one of the major DC
buildings.
Very interesting.
Okay. Although it is interesting, it
doesn't really show us that much. So, we
will continue.
All right.
Oh, here we go. All right. So, this is
not in English, by the way. It's in
Poland, but it's just a ton of
engravings that they will have on it.
Um, let me see if I can't come across
another.
Oh, very interesting. Ceremonial masonry
stone of the Los Angeles Central
Library.
That tells you right there apparently.
What else do they have here? Okay,
virgin
magnum
matre mat.
It's faded so I can't really read it.
But yes, that is one. So you get the
gist. There you go.
And so on.
Okay, that's really all the depth I
wanted to go into on that. But we will
get back to what I was saying on uh
looking up now
what these of course if you didn't know
that we'll just look up these kinds of
um concert
man my brain concert
halls perhaps look like you know most
all of us have been to one for shows of
any mind
and the buildings. They walk around them
cursing and carrying out their rituals
in preparation for everyone to arrive
and be mesmerized by the demons that
they have invoked to come into people
that night.
So
that's what we have is a bunch of
they're on top of it, by the way. They
really do all this and
they focus on this as a major ordeal.
It's one of their daily I shouldn't say
daily, but it's one of their duties.
Um,
and so
there you go. There's proof that that is
a thing. And
then we'll go to other things that we've
been talking about recently. Actually,
um, objects such as statues, of course,
carvings, ceremonial tools, or hidden
artifacts in buildings were
intentionally placed to serve as vessels
of influence. Yes, that is true. This is
the third thing that I'm talking about
historically, and that really by name is
Talisman's. If you've not heard of that,
that's an object that is hosted or been
cursed with the influence of a specific
demon to go with it.
They're created and charged, as they
say, during ceremonies to claim
authority over locations or people.
Rituals performed during the
construction, dedication, or operation
of these spaces are historically
documented as well.
They include offerings, symbolic acts
and ceremonies aligned with pagan or
occult esoteric or masonic traditions.
The purpose of all these objects and
rituals are to assert influence. Um you
might think of voodoo dolls or even a
booty
statue of Buddha that you might have
gotten from a country
um that worships that and you brought it
back as a souvenir. souvenirs from other
countries. Um, a lot of them are a bad
idea. They're just not not really a good
thing.
And so
they mark spiritual territory, empower
locations according to the beliefs of
the practitioner.
So the key facts are that these actions
and placements do happen, did happen,
and historically can be verified and are
recorded in multiple sources, including
Masonic records, architectural logs, and
firsthand
testimonies from people.
Now, we're getting somewhere. We're
building a record of the very things
that Satan tries to build up walls of
justifying that he owns us and that
there's nothing that we can do to get
away from him. He wants to claim
ownership over us.
But listen to this. There's one more
instrument which he gives which I think
you will find very troubling and
interesting.
So, he's not limiting himself either to
physical spaces. Satan tries to
manipulate our DNA, of course, through
GMOs and viruses and other toxins that
get into our body.
He even attempts to bind souls through
contracts
or institutions. This is what I was
talking about that is very different.
One such instrument is called Cestus
KV.
Go look this up. It is a very
controversial topic. However, I
believe it is true.
This is referred to as a historical
contract used to claim or bind human
souls
through a cult authorities tied to the
Vatican dating back to 1933.
The United States went off the gold
standard and some say went bankrupt
and needed help and was restructured
under the Federal Reserve.
This is said to have sold the souls of
the US citizens
to the Vatican in this contract.
Again, go look it up. A lot of sources
will tell you this is just fiction. This
doesn't exist. But when you go look
deeper,
I think it'll be interesting what you
find.
There's a key point through all of this.
Even this cannot defeat God.
You see when we go to scripture it has
the answers
and we will need to go then next to
James 4 verse 7.
All right. Don't look now but I'm going
to go really quick. Okay,
James.
Goodness.
All right. It's better just to type in
here, I think.
James
4 verse 7.
All right. So it says, "Submit
yourselves therefore to God and resist
the devil and he will flee from you."
These these things
are key,
very key. And I would add to that that
when we learn about scripture further,
although I don't have another scripture
to read about this, you will learn that
cleansing your space and your
possessions out of your house
is necessary, certain ones that are bad.
Remove anything used in occult rituals
or tied to ungodly influences.
Pray over your home, workplace, and your
body.
Even instruments like what we're talking
about,
Cestus KV, cannot stand against God's
power. And here is where I also need you
to hear me. No chip, no vaccine,
barcode, or anything else can stand
against God.
I believe that if that was coming to a
point where they were doing something
that took away our free will and even
our own consciousness
leading up to that very point, God knows
your heart still and he knows where you
are in your spiritual life
and
you won't be held responsible. If they
took somehow control over your body, you
wouldn't be responsible for the rest
because you are not home.
But to go on from there, we need to
understand further that Satan will try
everything. I've said this several
times. He will try everything. Marking
territory, manipulating systems,
manipulating you, altering DNA, claiming
souls, but he cannot win.
Romans 16:20 says, "The God of peace
will soon crush Satan under your feet."
1 John 3:8 says, "The reason the Son of
God appeared was to destroy the works of
the devil." Now, I'm going to go ahead
and search those because I want to make
sure.
Romans
16:20.
Perfect.
And the God of peace shall bruise Satan
under your feet shortly. The grace of
our Lord Jesus Christ be with you. Amen.
All right. So it does say that. Now
we'll go to the second verse I had there
which was 1 John
38.
It says he that committh sin is of the
devil. For the devil sinnth from the
beginning for this purpose the son of
God was manifested that he might destroy
the works of the devil.
All right. So yes that is true.
So,
let me again emphasize it because I
think we all need to hear it. If you're
like me, I've been getting kind of
I don't know, little burned out, a
little bit like, oh man, life goes on.
But, you know, this was an eye openener.
This was a breath of fresh air. And I
hope it is to you because
even when Satan uses of most extreme
schemes, viruses, genetic tampering,
contracts, occult institutions or
binding of souls, Satan will lose in the
end. God's victory is already
guaranteed.
But there is something I do have to
emphasize here
and that is
that we have a part to play in this. We
do
because
even if we just say I believe in you God
I give you control over my life.
I already point this out once but that's
not where our work ends.
We
have to resist temptation. That is the
biggest thing we have to do. We actually
have to turn away from all evil and
resist temptation. And as it says, Satan
will flee from you. Right?
You have to cleanse what is unholy out
of your life. Burn it. Get rid of it. I
hate to say this, but even if it's
addiction or character something or
other, it is better to pluck it out. And
I don't mean literally, but get rid of
it then to hold on to it.
Declare God's authority over your life,
your family, and your spaces.
Remember that every scheme of the en
enemy is temporary.
Every attempt to claim territory or your
soul is powerless against God.
Just a reminder that's coming to mind.
Only a third of the angels fell to the
earth with Satan when he was cast here.
So they are here too by the way in this
very space in your home again unless you
have asked for God's protection over
your entire home and the individuals in
your home and even to the the lengths of
I guess not just this room but your
entire house and so on.
Satan and his demons are present.
They are kind of lurking in the shadows
trying to
take hold of any opportunity you give
them
to trap you to put another snare in
front of you to go ahead
and get their hooks in you to get you to
fall.
So
you will be tempted.
You will be taunted
or even tortured for Jesus's name here
on earth.
But it cannot overcome the simple truth
that God remains the same.
That is that he is just righteous,
the one and only God that is blameless
above all. and he will be coming for you
and will be the winner. And if we
listen, that's the key word. If we,
which many people don't quite want to
hear either or pay attention to,
but only for those that do, hold fast to
him and submit to him
and overcome sin
will resist the devil
and watch as God continues to win,
not just for them,
but in you for his kingdom.
That is powerful
and we have to always remember that. So
do not give up the good fight. Do not
get tired. Oh my goodness, you guys. We
all get tired.
God knows this, too. Why do you think he
sends us stuff like this that all of a
sudden we're having worship and it's
like,
I am powerful and I can help you and I
will help you. I promise to never leave
or forsake you. You can do this. And
there's the promises in the Bible even
that he there's nothing we will go
through or can experience that he has
not gone through and overcome.
I know it's easier said than to know and
believe it. But
you guys, he is showing how he already
is promising and has overcome Satan. It
is a for sure thing.
Now we have to make it a for sure thing
in our life
in our personal battle
by resisting the devil, cleansing our
lives and our homes of anything ungodly,
holding on to God
and not letting go.
So remember that
God always wins and he will persevere.
One last promise he gives us is that he
says, "I will come to your aid. I will
fight for you. You need only to be
still."
Do you know that? That that is our job
is to remain steadfast
in knowing and standing in the truth
that we don't worry. we don't like freak
out and go hysterical,
but that we just kind of go, "God has my
back. I will resist the devil at any and
all costs, and he God has me.
And whatever happens,
he has me.
I will rely upon him and speak with him
and pray to him unceasingly, but I
can have the reassurance that he
wins. He knows what he's doing. He has
got you, my friend.
Lean on him, I guess, is all I can say.
So, I hope that was a great blessing.
Thank you guys for tuning in and may you
have
the warmth of God's love from this as
well.
All right, I'd like to go ahead and show
that um of course we have merchandise.
If you guys want it, go to our channel
to go ahead and shop for it. That is
candidtruth.org.
And these are the links to go ahead and
support us. We would appreciate it. We
love you guys. We appreciate so much all
of your support and love. Um and thank
you guys for everything.